so we're taking your calls at eight five
five two three six 32:28 eight five five
at two three six 32:28 Richard in
Orlando Florida you're on the bench beer
I go for it Richard so in 2016 we saw
President Trump just absolutely spanked
Hillary in the debates I mean crazy is
arguably the funny Scalia comedian of
all time but my question is you don't
think those toe to toe with Sanders in
the face and pummel them even harder
than he did Hillary in 2016 Democrats
seek to have him charged with elder
abuse hate crime because Sanders is
Jewish or both yeah I mean the the
answer is all of the above
right I mean it'll be presumably the
Jewish thing because they think that
they have room to run their but the
irony of that is that Bernie Sanders you
know claiming that he is reinvigorated
with his Jewish heritage is just an
absurdity on its face I mean this is a
person who not only was warm toward the
Soviet Union at a time when the Soviet
Union was banning Jews from leaving half
of his campaign surrogates are open
anti-semites Linda Sarsour who is one of
his campaign surrogates yesterday
literally is on tape saying that
Palestinians mistake is treating
Israelis like human beings they should
stop humanizing Israelis which is
basically a call for for the killing of
Jews and she's a campaign surrogate for
Bernie
Johan Omar and we're she to leave our
campaign surrogates for Bernie so you
know Bernie playing the Jewish card
against Trump I don't think that that
has any legs at all but you're right I
mean the problem for Bernie as opposed
to somebody like Camille Harris or Cory
Booker or somebody who actually has real
minorities standing or you know a Native
American like Elizabeth Warren it's
gonna be very hard for Bernie to claim
victimization at Trump's hands now the
thing that is a little bit different
from Trump and Bernie versus the Trump
Hillary dynamic is that Bernie is grumpy
and Bernie is irascible and Bernie is
rude and so and so I don't think he's
gonna sit there and try and play sort of
above the fray the way that Hillary
Clinton said it'll be down in the mud
between Trump and Sanders the
differences that Sanders is in the
communist mud that's a lot worse than
anything Trump has ever done politically
so yeah I don't think that that Sanders
claiming victimization at Trump's hands
is going to have any any play at all
Richard yeah no I agree I just you know
I was surprised after 2016 that they
they let Trump smack a woman on TV for
so long I figured they wouldn't stance
where he was doing that to an elderly
old man you know again I know we're
speaking figuratively but just for Media
Matters no one is in favor of hitting
women Richard really appreciate
arie in Stamford Connecticut you're on
the bench appear on channel 4 dari hey
Ben thanks for taking my call big fan
I just thought pulled that small
business owners that out of all the
Democratic candidates that uh Mike
Bloomberg would be the one to beat
Donald Trump is there anything to worry
about Bloomberg I mean does he actually
have any any sort of chance even to win
the primary or beat Trump in in that
case you know I think very unlikely the
Bloomberg wins the primary simply
because in order for him to do so he
basically has to split enough votes with
Bernie so that humans a plurality the
chances that he wants an outright
majority and the primaries are very low
considering that he's basically
boycotting all the primaries until he
gets a Super Tuesday which means he's
even boycotting South Carolina right now
if you're Bloomberg you're thinking
yourself that was a mistake maybe I
should have jumped in in South Carolina
maybe done some damage to Bernie in
South Carolina believe it or not
according Quinnipiac Bloomberg is
actually out polling Bernie among black
voters as far as whether Bloomberg would
have a chance against Trump I think he'd
have a better chance than Bernie would
against Trump mainly because he doesn't
hate capitalism I think that the the
obvious line for Trump to take against
Bernie is you like this economy well you
don't get to keep this economy if Bernie
is elected president which is a hundred
percent true Bloomberg for all of them
talk about how much Bloomberg is a
regulatory maven and and loves yeah just
banning soda and guns and all this stuff
he's not gonna be able to ban soda or
guns with with the Republican Congress
with a Republican Senate and also at
least he doesn't have a sort of
knee-jerk hatred for capitalism mean the
man is the ninth richest person on
planet earth he's not going to threaten
the economy in the same way so that that
line is not gonna work the same way it
would for Trump Trump is gonna make
Sanders the issue I mean see and Sanders
will be the issue deservedly so because
everybody is priced in Trump at this
point so this is why I always said that
Biden was not bad against Trump in in
general simply because he's a dead
person and that is the best person the
Democrats could run is basically an
inanimate object but Bloomberg is fairly
close to that the same is not true for
Bernie Bernie running against Trump I
think the conventional wisdom is
probably correct about this that that
well you know I hate the idea of a
communist even having any shot at the
presidency at all he is definitely the
most vulnerable against Trump
considering that again I don't think the
American people are ready to revoke
capitalism as a whole at this point no
matter what an octogenarian socialist
loon bag who's never done anything
useful in his entire life has to say
well thanks man I appreciate that
thanks so much Andy and Tucson Arizona
here on the bench appearance I go for
dandy
I bet and thanks for taking my call
I had a few questions about article I
read in Arizona public media regarding a
2016 law we passed here in Arizona to
prevent the collecting of mail-in
ballots it is very important to us here
because almost 70% of our ballots but in
the 2018 were mail-in ballots and the
Ninth Circuit Court has overturned this
law on the grounds of discrimination so
wanted to know how is this
discriminatory and doesn't this set a
national precedent and the fact that
anybody collecting a mail-in ballot
doesn't that jeopardize the validity I
hate ballot harvesting I think ballot
harvesting is garbage the idea that
you're supposed to go door to door to
specific people who you know are voting
for your party and then you just grab
the ballots first of all I think it's a
recipe for voter fraud because what you
know the let's say that you are paying
volunteers to do this sort of thing and
at a certain rate in our now those
people are obviously biased toward a
particular point of view let's say that
you run out of people in your precinct
who are who are voting for a particular
candidate so you just move on to another
precinct and you pick up ballots that
have not necessarily been filled in or
haven't been filled in at the top of the
ticket he's not done in bipartisan
fashion so I hate ballot harvesting on
but by the way I also think that the the
generalized attitude which is that we
need to make voting easier I disagree
with this I don't think we should put
obstacles in the way of voting but I
think that it's a good thing that you
have to go down to your local ballot box
and you have to vote I mean I think that
making voting easier online all it does
is it lowers the barrier of entry for
people who are not invested in politics
at all and who are following this stuff
the way they would follow American Idol
I don't think people should elect and I
think they should seriously consider how
they vote I think that they should have
to take time out of their day to do so
and I think that's a good thing
harvesting ballots seems to me one of
the more corrupt things that you can do
in American politics and frankly I'm
shocked at that folks on both sides of
the aisle seem not to be more upset
about ballot harvesting which again
really is more about the organizational
turnout of your volunteer squad than it
is about how many votes are actually out
there because now you've actually set an
uneven playing field let's say that
you're in a precinct where Democrats
have hired 10 people to go gather
ballots and Republicans have hired 5
people to gather ballots and you're
sitting at home waiting for somebody to
gather your ballot
but you're a Republican and you not as
many people are out gathering ballots so
now you've got a fully filled out ballot
you were counting on somebody to show up
at your door to pick up that ballot and
nobody's doing so like is this a good
idea now is it now it's really about not
even turnout efforts but how many cars
he have canvassing the neighborhood I
think it's a terrible idea I think the
ninth circuit is ridiculous
I think that there is nothing in the
Constitution that suggests that ballot
harvesting is mandatory under the
Constitution its absurdity on its face
and II really appreciate the call Gavin
in South Carolina here on the bench
appearance our good friend Gavin so as a
results from the Iowa caucuses were
obviously controversial what are your
thoughts on the implementation of
Internet polling versus traditional
booth voting and you think it could have
an impact on the 2020 election so I
think that Internet polling is is
generally a bad idea for all the reasons
I just outlined I think that most people
are able to click on an app and flip a
switch and I guess it makes voting more
plentiful but again it lowers the
barrier for voting also tends to bias in
favor specifically of younger voters who
can't be bothered to go vote normally
I'm very much in favor again of
traditional voting booths you should
have to go you should have to do your
public service you should have to do
your duty go over to the voting booth
wait in line get the dumbest sticker do
all of those things also the Internet is
easily hackable as we saw in in Iowa
these apps do not work the way they are
supposed to very often and you worry
about Russian interference in the
election wait until we're not using
traditional voting booths wait until
there's one app that if the Chinese
Hacket they can now control American
elections you want you want election
security to go down dramatically Gavin
seems to me the Internet polling is the
best way to do that thank you thank you
I agree I thank you for taking my call
well Kevin I really appreciate it
Christian in Los Angeles you're on the
bench Shapiro should I go for a question
I had a couple questions same question
kind of in two subjects for health care
and for the Second Amendment I haven't
been up to date on those two in a while
primarily my argument for the Second
Amendment the key is to keep it and I'm
all for all sorts of weapons that we
make but a lot of times it comes up why
do we need to keep larger weapons
you know like with automatic magazines
and whatnot and I say my typical
difference against that is that it's
just in in our constitution for four
years now I mean why would that need to
change although I can see the
that is something that yes I mean I I
would like a better sure so this is the
typical defense given in favor of the
Second Amendment is the original
rationale of the Second Amendment which
is to dissuade the government from
tyranny and by the way one of the signs
of tyranny is the government coming to
take your guns
the founders always foresaw that an
armed population would be the greatest
check against a government coming to do
you harm and coming to violate your
rights and historically speaking Martin
Luther King owned a gun the reason he
owned a gun is because he was very much
afraid of people harming his family
traditionally dispossessed populations
have been disarmed before the
dispossession specifically in order to
lower the risk of tyranny so having
rifles available to do just that makes a
lot of sense now
again the goal isn't to actually use
those things the goal is to dissuade
people from from actually attempting
tyranny in the first place it's a
deterrence effort right the reason that
the United States has nuclear weapons is
not because we ever want to use nuclear
weapons it's to prevent anybody else
from using nuclear weapons against us
well the reason you have an armed
population is to raise the possibility
the to raise the cost of a possible
tyrannical imposition by saying okay
listen if you try this there will be a
cost to this that's why Joe Biden
idiotically suggested the other day well
you know if there were ever a conflict
between the US government and the
American population rifles wouldn't do
it well again the that is not really the
goal first of all it's not true I mean
we've seen in Vietnam in Afghanistan
we've seen in Iraq that insurgencies
armed with rifles can do an awful lot of
damage but beyond that the general idea
is people should have to think twice
before they violate deeply held rights
in the United States and one of those
deeply held rights is in fact the
ability to defend yourself and your
property from violation of those rights
not just by the government by other
people who are coming to do you harm
which which obviously is something that
happens most people in the United States
who own rifles are doing so at least in
part for reasons of self-defense and I
own a shotgun a long gun for for
purposes of self-defense so handguns
it'd be weird tired you also it's also
very weird that people on the left are
constantly arguing about why handguns
should be legal but rifles should not be
legal far more people in the United
States are murdered with handguns and
rifles it is not a close call so so if
they're gonna call for a ban on guns
really what they should be doing is
calling for a ban on handguns rather
than a ban on rifles but they're not
willing to do that because they
recognize that a lot of people own
handguns
be nearly impossible to disarm all of
them so they start with rifles instead
because rifles look scary as in military
as opposed to handguns
even though handguns do far more damage
on a daily basis in the hands of the
wrong people in the United States than
rifles do Christian really appreciate
your call Josh in Washington State
you're on the bench pH I go for Josh hey
Ben how's it going longtime fan and I
just want to get your thoughts on the
federal government basically suing King
County over King County not allowing ice
to deport illegal aliens at a Boeing
Field a currently Isis to transport
legal aliens over 150 miles to Yakima
is this going to basically set a
precedent for the federal government
suing different cities and counties and
municipal areas in the future what is
this what are your thoughts on that I
mean that wouldn't be surprised we've
seen the sort of state versus federal
lawsuit before most most prominently
ashrams we got a drug law right there
was there's a whole federal lawsuit
against the state of California over
marijuana legalization and in a case
called the rage versus California the
the federal government suing King County
for basically being a sanctuary City I
would not be surprised if this becomes
precedent and frankly the federal
government does have precedents in this
particular area I mean just for folks
who have missed the story there's a
flight ban which went into effect last
spring because King County Executive Dow
Constantine signed in order to
renegotiate leases on land that flight
operators used and a prompted ice to use
an airport in Yakima and the move was
operating an additional cost to drive
detainees the 150 mile trip to Yakima so
US Attorney William Hyslop this is all
according to mynorthwest.com explained
in a news conference on Monday the
detainees being transported have been
deemed a risk to the community safety or
have been previously deported he says
this is illegal immigration is
prohibited by federal law you cannot bar
us from using the airport in this way so
that is I would not be surprised if the
Trump administration particularly starts
doing this and frankly they should
because there is the concept of federal
supremacy in areas that the federal
government occupies when it comes to
immigration law it is one thing for
these states say we are not going to
become a tool of your immigration policy
that the that is perfectly plausible and
you can say that it's another thing to
bar us from actually doing its job
inside your own state that is a totally
different thing Josh
I'll say one more thing a buddy of mine
sent me a text last night about the visa
CBP operating the border patrol on
Native American burial lands the federal
government has been consulting farmers
and landowners about this for the past
couple months now do you think they
should treat the Native Americans any
differently with consultation or what do
you think they should try and move
around it what are your thoughts on the
on the on the border wall going to the
burial sites well I mean I actually
don't know enough about the treaty
stipulations between the Native American
sites the Native American tribes that
have control over the land and the in
the US government because these are
considered that they're sort of in a
weird gray area because these are
sovereign tribal lands and so you
actually have to negotiate with the
individual tribe over all of this and
that's very different from the federal
government simply sort of deciding the
rules on on Native American tribal
territory so I'd actually want to check
that out before right before I give you
an answer I just don't know enough about
it Josh really appreciate the call
Zachary in Wisconsin you're on the bench
pure struggle for exactly then I was
just wondering what your position was on
legalizing prostitution so my general
position on legalizing prostitution is
that we already have laws on the books
that bar trafficking in women and abuse
of women and I'm not sure that you have
to have laws that specifically target
voluntary consensual exchange of sex for
money now I think that that's horrible
and disgusting I think it's inherently
exploitative of women I think it's bad
for men I think it's horrible for women
and all the rest but I I do not think
that the government generally has a role
in consensual exchange that is actually
consensual I think we as a culture ought
to fight against it I think we as a
culture ought to say this is gross and
bad I think we ought to have social
stigmas that attach to utilizing
prostitution I think there can be local
zoning ordinances for example they don't
allow you to open a whorehouse and I
think all of that is perfectly
appropriate but but the idea of the of
there being criminal penalties for
trading sex for money you know if
there's a contract signed or something
but I don't I don't think that that's
necessarily the government's ability to
get involved again I think there are
ways to to sort of prevent it from
infiltrating your neighborhood that's
what zoning regulations are for I think
there are rules on the books that
prevent victimization of women are
should and so I'm not sure that the
broad-based policy of banning
prostitution actually achieves what it
is seeking to achieve I will say that
Zachary okay thank you I appreciate your
call okay let's take one more Leon say
in Columbus Ohio you're on the bench up
here I shall go for at Leon say I'm glad
to take my call page I'll tell you that
I really like you're the person but I
disagree with you a lot on policy sure
and particularly I don't understand why
you're against identity politics when it
comes to african-americans when people
on the right often cite things like
anti-semitism they call it on Omar and
Semitic persimmon it was all about the
Benjamins
I don't see how that is inherently
anti-semitic the same way that you and
other people on the right would say that
the things that Donald Trump says about
Haitian cultures is inherently anti
black okay so there anti-semitism is a
kind of weird breed Leon say in the
sense that the the the rips on on Jews
are very often not connected with
ethnicity sometimes there's sort of
religious anti-semitism Judaism being a
so-called gutter religion according to
Louis Farrakhan be an example of that or
rips on Jews culturally so Judaism is
sort of anti-semitism and racism are not
completely equivalent just because the
definition of Jews encompasses both it
incomes his ethnicity it also
encompasses religion and culture so it's
kind of broader as far as Trump ripping
on quote-unquote Haitian culture like
when he said that I assume you're
talking about the the bleep holes
comments for example when he said that
certain countries are bleep holes
so the so it's not inherently racist to
suggest that certain countries are less
well-run than others I mean I think we
can agree that some countries are less
well-run than others if president said
black people create places that are
bleep holes that would be racist right
that would be an openly racist statement
if he says that Haiti is kind of a bleep
hole well I mean frankly I think
California's kind of a bleep hole and I
live here so I think it sort of depends
on how it's being put I think there are
people who have made racist comments I
think that there are something the Trump
had said that are that are borderline
racist maybe even crossing over into
that area I don't really see saying that
Haiti is is kind of a bleep hole to live
in for example as a racist take I also
don't see the thing like Baltimore is is
infested is racist because Baltimore
does have a rat problem there are white
areas that rat problem is to Leonce a
right rate what about the anti-semitism
of Ilan Omar that comet is that
inherently anti-semitic well she's as I
say so the the kind of rip on ohan Omar
with regard to this is that there is a a
long-standing stereotype of Jews that
Jews are perverting American
institutions using Jewish money and so
when she says that American support for
Israel is all about the Benjamins and
then she explicitly references a Jewish
group that is supposedly using its money
to influence politics that plays into a
generalized stereotype about Jews in the
same way that's saying that you know if
you said that that black people create
bad cultures right then that would be a
racist thing to say so that would be
sort of the equivalent there gotcha okay
but I guess I have to get off the phone
I just think that those are kind of
synonymous with each other where they
both are inherently racist are
interesting well I definitely appreciate
the critique and Leon say thanks so much
for listening I appreciate the call
especially since he disagrees so so
often we really appreciate it